well we've got this rosetta spacecraft
it's arrived at a comet
it's looking down at the comet it's
about 100 kilometers above a comet
called comet 67p
for a comet and it's it's orbiting a
comet and actually it's not orbiting in
a circle which i think is quite neat one
of the things that it's doing is it's
orbiting in a sort of triangle because
the gravity i associate with the comet
is so so small
that actually it doesn't sort of have
the pull to keep the uh these spacecraft
in orbit in a circular orbit so they're
having to turn on the
the rockets on the spacecraft to
sort of turn it round the corner of the
triangle
let sir isaac do his work newton's first
law shoots down to the next corner and
then he comes around so it's just going
around this comet it's now about five
405 million kilometers from earth
it's the the comet's heading
towards the you know it's an orbit that
goes around the sun uh
it's currently between i think about
mars and jupiter
and so it's remarkable right this thing
has traveled all that way it's actually
traveled something like six billion
kilometers in order to get there the way
it's had to
use gravity of the sun use gravity of
the earth use the gravity of of mars in
order to accelerate itself out to this
fast distance right and then it's had to
slow itself down so that it's now
traveling
to within about i think it's something
like one meter per second of the
uh
comet itself which which itself is
traveling at a mere 55 000 kilometers
per hour it's pulled up alongside but
it's 100 kilometers up and is just now
going around it and and will gradually
over the next few months work its way
down i think it's going to do it's going
to go down to it's hoping to go down to
a 50 kilometer um orbit and then if it
can it's going to they've got to keep
checking they have no idea what what
it's like down there and so then they're
going to try and go down i think to
about 30 kilometers
and look around and now now they're
going to look for places where
they've got a
lander on the spacecraft that they're
going to then fire down to the
to land somewhere on the comet so
they're going to try and decide where's
the best place to land if they can even
land it down there
of course and the idea is to try and
understand what the comet's made of
what's what's in it
comets are thought of as as they've got
this mystical image about them you know
when you look in the sky and those
beautiful tails and they you know
they're made of ice and dust and
in days gone by they were associated
with
usually some cataclysmic events but uh
actually we believe they could be part
of the fundamental building blocks of
the solar system and maybe maybe of of
life on earth they one of the tests
they'd like to do is to see whether or
not there are any amino acids
in the comet i mean they've actually
been doing analysis of this for a few
months because it's not that you know
you don't send the spacecraft off it's
comes shooting in at 55 000 kilometers
an hour plus one and then slow it down
and slow it down sort of overnight it's
taken months to do this but that means
they've been able to take pictures and
actually they've got lot they've got
lots of
detectors on the spacecraft and so
they've already been taking images of of
the dust that's coming off of of the the
temperature of it the lights the the
coma which makes it surrounds the the
comet one of the unusual things i was
reading about is that's been getting
lighter and darker over a six week
period and i don't think people were
really expecting that
but and one of the things that tickled
me was that they've been getting water
they're detecting water vapor coming off
and it's coming off at about the the
rate of a of a a can of coca-cola
a second you know the equivalent of the
volume and it's about 300 milliliters a
second coming off